hey this is uh I think some of you may
find this interesting we launched the
Pacman Finance Channel we announced this
a while ago and I'll remind you what
that is in a moment and the comments on
this channel are pure and utter gold
where I am both being called a Socialist
Communist who has no business talking
about personal finance and also being
called a capitalist who is bad
like Alex Jones says oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad and for that reason people aren't
going to watch the channel so let's back
it up a little bit about a month and a
half ago we announced the forthcoming
launch of the Pacman Finance YouTube
channel this will be a channel
it's not a political channel it's
personal finance
with
someone who is on the left rather than
like right-wing Dave Ramsey so the way I
like to think about Pac-Man Pac-Man
Finance is it's like Dave Ramsey but not
a right-wing nut not irrationally
obsessed with avoiding debt and not
anti-vaxx that that's the way I that's
the elevator pitch for Pac-Man finance
and it took us a while to get this
launched and we finally did
there are currently two videos up one
about building a logical asset
allocation and another one for how to
build an emergency fund and the right
order of operations for one's finances
incredibly after just
24 48 Hours of videos we are already at
3750 subscribers to this brand new
channel it's incredible I can't thank
people enough and you can find the
channel at youtube.com pacmanfinance
it's no frills personal finance how to
make a budget
why home prices and interest rates move
in opposite directions
index funds just Basics okay youtube.com
Pacman Finance but the really
interesting thing is I've been on
politics YouTube for a decade and a half
and I know about the kind of toxic
nature of what's on politics YouTube now
being exposed to finance YouTube it's
absolutely fascinating check out some of
these comments that I spotted our friend
Tommy Boy
showed up and said shouldn't you just
wait for the government to give you
everything you need to survive
I I don't know when I've ever advocated
for that and then Tommy Boy adding this
is comical a complete socialist talking
about asset allocation laughable
hypocrisy if you know anything about me
and my channels it's that I am not a
socialist I am a Social Democrat that's
a well-regulated type of capitalism so
Tommy Boy is confused then we continue
with people with a different perspective
Sergeant salty showed up and said more
capitalist lives you can get rich too if
you follow this advice that's not what I
said you cannot find a single place
where I even imply that
Sergeant salty goes on to say how about
instead of playing into the system
advocate for a new system that people
don't have to struggle to succeed in
well come over to my David Patman Show
YouTube channel
where I advocate for exactly that type
of change zephyrus commented I refuse to
watch capitalist content so some people
won't watch it because it's communist
and some people won't watch it because
it's capitalism okay a couple others
stig's Journey said why is a communist
talking about finances
hmm and then Mr Rembrandt said why would
a progressive anti-capitalist start a
finance Channel
well
where are you getting that I think
capitalism is broken
but I'm not a socialist and I'm not a
communist and then lastly this is my
favorite
Jason Crawford asks a really good
question what actual expertise do you
have in personal finance that's a fair
question
I have an MBA
specialized
in financial planning
that's my expertise and I hope that it
is suitable
uh folks we've got a real problem out
there so as a reminder I will outline I
am an adherent to social democracy I'm
fine with markets being used to direct
resources in some areas
broadcast microphones fine supply and
demand put it in the market
um you know hipster sneakers
fine
but I want certain areas out of that
when we talk about health care when we
talk about education there are certain
things I don't think should be subjected
to vulture capitalism and the whims of
the market everybody should have a home
everybody should have health care
everybody should have food we can do
these things okay and as a Social
Democrat which is a well-regulated form
of capitalism I believe that we should
use taxation on the very rich
to ensure that nobody drops below a
certain level a certain standard of
living we should be funding maternity
and paternity leave we should be using
those funds to make sure that we are
taking care of people the rich can still
be rich but the Richer you get we're
going to take a bigger and bigger slice
to make sure everybody's doing okay
if you want to call that socialism
you're wrong
if you want to call that unregulated
capitalism you're also wrong we're
talking about a regulated form of
capitalism okay so that's the deal we
don't do Politics on the finance Channel
we do the politics here but again I
encourage you to go to youtube.com
pacmanfinance be one of the first 5 000
subscribers it's free guys it's
completely free next video comes out
today we've got another video coming out
tomorrow it's an absolutely fantastic
thing